what are you doing later I'm working at
the hardware store till 7 I'll have
Taylor pick you up
then I would like to bite the
lip I think I'd like that
too I'm not going to touch you not until
I have your written
consent
what I'll explain later come on take you
[Music]
home the
paperwork
I what is it about
elevators part of this week just be on
this
door what is my
playroom like your Xbox and
stuff it's important that you know you
can leave at any time why what's in
there I meant what I said
the helicopter's and standby to take you
whenever you want to go could just open
the
[Music]
door oh my
God
[Music]
let's call the
fogger say something
please do women do this to you or do you
I do this to women with women women who
want want me
to you're a
sadist I'm a dominant what does that
mean it means I want you to willingly
surrender yourself to
me why would I do that to please me to
please
you how I have rules if you follow them
I'll reward you if you don't I'll punish
you you'd punish me like you'd use this
stuff on
me
yes what would I get out of
[Music]
this
me Christian I cannot walk that fast in
these
shoes when are we going to to tell me
about Georgia what you have no right to
be mad yeah but I am mad Palm twitching
me
mad
ow you're mine all mine you
understand Christian you are so
confusing Anna what do you want
what do you want I want
you I'm trying
Christian I know you
are why can't we sleep in the same
bed why won't you let me touch
you why does it have to be like
this if you just signed the contract you
you wouldn't have to think about you
care so much about the contract
Christian don't you like me the way I
am of course I do and why are you trying
to change me I'm
not it's I need more I want
more hearts and
flowers that's not something I
know and a
place it's you that's changing me
let me touch
you let
me are they
Burns I had a rough start in life that's
all you need to
know okay
please don't hate
me you'll never do that to me
again I'm not what you
w no you were everything that I
want
I fallen in love with
you no no Anna you can't love
me I need you to
leave
please
for
I'd like my car
back Taylor already sold
it then I'd like the money he got for it
please I'll send you a
check
okay Taylor will take you
home
stop
no h
Christian Anna you will be sitting here
darling right next to Carrie Christian
welcome ladies and gentlemen to our
annual
ball as you know proceeds from this
evening will go to the charity that
Grace and I founded so many years ago
coping together working to make life
better for the children of parents
addicted to drugs everything okay and
now thankfully I will be handing off my
speaking duties to our Master of
Ceremonies Mr nit
Paul thank you Mr Gray and thank you
ladies and gentlemen hungry let's start
the bidding with Lot number one do I
hear
$10,000 now you know what those silver
balls do $15,000
$115,000 going once going twice
sold that's a great start ladies and
gentlemen now Lot number two a weeks
vacation at a luxury Chalet in Aspen
Colorado donated by Mr Christian
Gray let's start the B offer $110,000
$10,000 thank you ma'am
$10,000 I didn't know you got a place an
houseand 15,000 a lot of boy we have
some ski lers in the room tonight
177,000 $177,000 thank you sir1 188,000
$118,000 thank you do I hear 19 19 19
$199,000 thank you you sir a week of
luxury in America's Finest ski resort
$24,000 New Blood
$24,000 I am bid do I hear 25,000 the
money was for you and now it'll go to
someone who needs it looks as if the
young lady I don't know whether worship
at your feet or spank you
$24,000 going
once think go going twice take option
two sold to the young lady in silver
[Applause]
your generosity really makes a
difference ladies and gentlemen so let's
see if we can do even better with Lot
number three the chance
[Music]
to I
was was mine but it was all
[Applause]
[Music]
good
you were gone and I was back and I was
good and bad but it
was I want you to SP
me take off your
panties do I
now right in here yeah right here
now go
on
[Music]
for
excuse
me leaves the
call of your heart strength to play soft
and low yet all the
Night Magic seem to
[Music]
whisper and all the
soft Moonlight seems to
shine you're
BL can I just have one more more
with
you my
love can I just make some more romance
with
you
[Music]
dance
in I just have one dance with
you my
[Music]
love
no 2 minutes are you kidding in the pict
are you
joking
it's after
midnight I'm not
tired
no it's your
birthday
yeah happy
birthday thank
you do you still have that gift I gave
you
[Music]
you know you doesn't have
to all I want is you just open it
[Music]
okay
keychain turn it over
[Music]
does this mean yes yes
yes yes yes
[Music]
yes
wait so this whole time I had the answer
in my
pocket Anastasia Ste what am I going to
De with
[Music]
you come with me there's something I
need to show
you last time we came down here I was
over your shoulder
oh
[Music]
yeah how de
you
oh my
God you want to find some flowers oh my
God it's okay it's
[Music]
okay
Christian this is
[Music]
amazing
be
mine share my life with
me yes bury
me I'll bury
you come
[Music]
here
did you do
[Music]
that is
pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
you know know I can't go to New York I
have to work take it with you I have
meetings reschedule I have to show up I
have responsibilities you can't keep me
in a cage I just want you to be safe I
will be safe I have Sawyer and
Prescott I'll be
fine you need a
haircut not the priority I can do it no
yeah I used to cut my dad's hair all the
time I don't it look like your
father oh
[Music]
okay you don't have to be so cautious if
you'll Practice What You
Preach counting up the stacks on the
counter I
[Music]
don't ask me to be righteous and
still practice what you
teach counting on all your blessings the
second you're down on your
[Music]
knee Christian
what dring me you
done when we're running out of
time so
why okay enough enough
where are the scissors in my desk wait
here don't move I'm not going
[Music]
anywhere
hello welcome home M
did
Christian where is everybody elsewhere
I thought you were mad at
me turn
[Music]
around we're going to the
playroom
[Music]
ask
true don't have to tell
you oh I love your precious heart I
[Music]
was you were
there to
colling and they could
nice
one there you are who was looking for
you you all right I couldn't
sleep you want to talk about it I've
already talked to pint of ice cream
about
it I'll make you some tea
oh
oh I'm so sorry woo not
fun oh God it's dripping I'll get
[Music]
it hard
to was
M
[Music]
many
imagine
it's oh good boys go to heaven but Bad
Boys bring Heaven to you
it's
automatic it's just what they
do they say oh good boys go to heaven
but Bad Boys bring Heaven to you don't
realize the power they have until they
leave you you're the only thing I want
to
touch never knew that it could mean so
much so so
much you're the fear I don't care cuz
I've never been so high follow me
through the dark let me take it fast s
the
light you can see the world you brought
to
life to
life so love me like you do la la love
me like you do love me like you do la la
love me like you do Touch Me Like You Do
touch me like you
do what are you waiting
for love me like you do love me like you
do you do love me like you do love me
like you
do me like you do touch me like you
do
what are you waiting
for fading in fading out on the edge of
paradise every inch of your skin is a
holy gra I've got to
find only you can set my heart on
fire on
fire yeah I let you set the
pace cuz I'm not thinking
stra my ha sping around I can't see kid
no
more what are you waiting
[Music]
for so you want to
play yes
[Music]
sir
you're topping from the bottom Mrs
[Music]
Gray but I can live with
that what are you waiting
for